that this narrative which we were all  lied to about inflated an organization  that purported to be about black lives  mattering  I went into the finances what did you  find what I found was that millions and  millions of dollars are going to trans  organizations hmm what kind of  organizations quite literally trans  organizations like we focus on providing  trans houses one was we are focused on  building the first ever fully  transgender District in San Francisco we  are focused on if they're all buying  houses in building districts I'll say  that it's a lot of real estate we are  focused on providing a Oasis for  transgendered people in Ohio right house  of Gigi House of tulip  um a transgender District we are focused  on sex workers all sex workers how does  any of this go to furthering black lives  right we found that 30 plus million  dollars went to the stock market I  thought this was about tearing down the  institutions of white supremacy